few people know their way around the
restaurant better than the world famous
chef michelle roo and i
to my great pleasure can speak to him
now
good morning mr roo
morning trevor you can call me chef good
morning absolutely
you absolutely on money good morning
chef um
look your family's been running
restaurants for uh generations um
how bad is it now
it's really dreadful it's terrible um i
mean on a very serious note this is as
bad as um march in uh 2020 the first
lockdown
the biggest issue for me is the lack of
communication from the government uh
there are no
um
we're being told one thing uh
the public has been told one thing so
don't go out don't don't you know don't
go to christmas parties
and don't congregate in numbers
um which in turn means that people
aren't going out or cancelling christmas
parties canceling events um and and
being very careful now it could be quite
rightly so because of this pandemic
which which is awful and it is real um
but it means that
what should be our most prosperous month
as restaurateurs and as hoteliers and
republicans um is now turning into a
loss because people are not turning up
so
i'm all right with locking down don't
get me wrong locking down is a good
thing if it's going to save lives and it
means that the nhs is not going to be
put under pressure i mean lord knows
that the nhs is doing
an unbelievable job you know fantastic
job and and you know praise to them and
of course let's not forget all the
volunteers because also the roll out of
the um of the booster and of the jabs in
the first time round uh it's not thanks
to the government it's thanks to the nhs
and thanks to the volunteers so what we
need in our industry and not just in our
industry is clear government proper
proper government with a pair of cojones
that takes decisions on time not waffle
what would you like to hear
from the prime minister over the next
couple of weeks
clear decisions it it really is simple
as that um trevor i mean
we we don't know whether we're coming or
going in our industry we are losing uh
business we are losing livelihoods um i
have and
also very very important point because
we're talking about hospitality industry
here which which employs you know to
2.5 3 million people directly and
what about the ecosystem around the
hospitality industry so
all the drivers that come and deliver
our goods all the security the cleaners
the
the collection of refuse the suppliers
the supply chain is immense i've i've
had supplies on the phone in tears
asking me to take some produce but i
can't take produce i've had a collapse
of bookings
and i don't know whether i'm going to be
open tomorrow let alone next week so you
know we need clear decisions and if we
get locked down um then
we need compensation we need financial
help and again i reiterate not just the
hospitality industry but across the
board
we need proper firm government and a
government that we can respect
give us a picture of what this level of
uncertainty means in your business for
you know one of your one of your
restaurants or one of your family's
restaurants
yes i mean i i tweeted recently last
week about my um daughter's restaurant
and this is a you know a new business a
new restaurant with with a big debt
and that's another thing a lot of
restaurants you know
small businesses
are already laden with debt and we're
getting help yeah we have to take a loan
out and that's another debt that's
adding debt on debt
so that i don't consider that help
financially but anyway that's another
story so
she she was um
building up to a prosperous december a
december that would see her through the
lean months of dry january uh and
february and march
they're
normally quiet months
so in this industry we need to build up
reserves in november and december to see
us through well that's gone that's
finished
nothing left so we're now she is now
into a lost situation business-wise uh
in december
the chancellor's just come back from
california industry leaders are saying
that some businesses are going to go out
go
going to sink they're going to go under
um
what what practical help
would work for you what would you like
to hear rishi sunak announce
once he's done his sums
um well first of all we need assurance
going forward so next year the vat is
likely to go back up to 20 well um
it would help immensely if it was either
kept at 12 and a half or taken back down
to five and business rates need sorting
out that it's the most unfair system
ever um and then
uh statutory sick pay is one that i
would like to see reformed as well
because at the moment um people who are
catching covid uh with very mild
symptoms um are thinking well shall i go
to work or shall i you know
shall i just take statutory sick pay you
can't survive on that you can't pay the
rent you can't
there's no way so and then the burden is
put on back on the employer that's not
right so you know
there are a number of number of things
but if we are going to go into lockdown
and as i said i'm not against lockdown
i'm really not if it's for the right
reason but we need to know
we can't have this dilly dallying around
and this waffle that's coming out of the
government at the moment
um
you are of course uh proudly british
british michelle rue we claim you 100 as
our own but of course you have some
french heritage um
what do you think about the french uh
decision to essentially ban travel
between here and there
uh what it's a firm decision
uh i mean the one thing whether you you
you know you like or dislike mac hall he
takes decisions uh and that's another
thing i think there's a lot of
politicking going on between mack hall
and uh
uh and boris johnson um
yeah well one thinking he's uh napoleon
bonaparte and the other one thinking
he's winston churchill uh come on guys
get out get out of the playground and
and behave properly but
you know at least uh decisions are made
and they are made quickly and with
direction it was the same with the
lockdown back in uh 2020 uh macon took
this decision to
close the restaurants uh early uh or
close down the whole country early and
to police it properly firmly uh and to
put uh you know a proper package to help
uh the hospitality industry um and
that's you know i think that's all we
want and it's not just the hospitality
industry it's what everybody wants is
clear decision making
um it is a politics program so i i i'm
tempted to ask you about goose versus
turkey also but i have to ask you a
proper question uh it looks like there
might be
another lock down
do you think that
the industry can survive another one
um if there's adequate compensation then
um
yes there will still be some casualties
and another thing which i've not spoken
about is is mental health it is it it
really is
incredibly tough um i mean
two days ago i had team members staff
members at my restaurant asking me are
we shutting are we not shutting um and
and
the consequences of that uh and uh tears
in their eyes welling up i mean really
not knowing whether they've got a job or
not and we're trying to entice people
back into the hospitality industry so
you know how do how is this going to
work it is incredibly difficult times um
so
it's not just you know not just one
thing it's very very difficult but but
we need as i said before and i keep on
saying it is a strong government that
that will take decisions and and give us
proper proper help
mitchell roo it's been a pleasure
talking to you thank you so much
thank you